my name is Rachel I work in a front-end
graphics so today I'm going to talk
about some of the updates as you already
know we have a high DPI support for
Linux and GNU and windows and this of
course it's including graphics and also
the rasterization functionality and we
are also having texture mapping for more
3d primitives and adding an list of name
the vertex texture coordinates so you
don't have to figure out how to creating
the texture cornice yourself and we and
we also have an interactive way to
picking the view Center so if we want to
rotate around a certain object you want
to check more details it's a it's a
camellia it's very convenient way and we
also have some nam MPO rendering
features and which is as directives and
also I'm going to talk about a little
surface appearance you how do you use
the recipients to customize your own
rendering after that probably talk about
later but our new joining layers we
spend a lot of time on those and these
now are ready and fully implemented so
high DPI for graphics it's it's
supported everywhere ordering rails or
primitives and also each components like
tick tick labels as well and it also
supported you can also rasterize it
converter and then if we take a look
let's see there's uh okay
there's back there let me switch to a
hundred percent let's try again so if we
take a look the the it was says like I'm
trying to see where is it I didn't okay
and issues oh okay yeah that's because
the projector so on my laptop it would
be 144 and the data image data will be
double the image size let me switch 200
okay so it works with 3d as well work
with Mesa as well so text mapping we
have text mapping for the rest of 3d
graphics 3d primitives and and one thing
I want to mention that we now have some
it changes the default value of vertex
texture coordinates is used to be now
but now it's automatic so it might
affect some of the examples you had
previously so before in 12 will be
likely in this example it will not apply
and it plies here but if you want to
switch to the previous one you can
either define some of the style sheet or
you can specify a texture of not
directly so texture mapping is useful
but sometimes it you may get hard time
to to figure out how to create a vertex
texture cornets so we provide a list of
name the ones to provide to generate for
you
planner is the floodway you applying
textures Allah or either X or Y or Z
direction so it would be like this
this is flying to Z direction and this
prize to Y direction you can see and
there's another one called cubic
applying textures or sixth texture it
were map the polygons into a cube and
then apply six
textures allows us those six faces and
the cubic is three direction the box is
six direction so the cubic is top top
and bottom you'll be same but the box it
would be it would be different so yeah I
wanna be useful for different users and
the spherical is just trying to map the
part in the paragraphs to unit sphere
and then apply it around or XYZ
directions you can specify there's
syntax there but but sometimes you might
wonder why just XYZ directions what if I
want to something different direction
you can do that it worked with Jeremy
transformation what you need to do is
just just for the core needs and then
just form the whole thing back it just
applies in inverse and here's an example
so you can do different so that means
you can do any direction interactive
view Center picking so if you hold on
it's in product already and if you hold
down shift and option and it was it was
show up picking icon and so then it was
what it does do I said this object has
view center if there are some nothing to
to pick em I have no it does not change
anything but there's if there's anything
could be hit both than the word it would
be chain it would be changed and
yeah so it might be useful if you have a
lot of objects you want to checking more
details somehow some part of it and the
MPO what is the appeal is its more arted
artistic way of rendering objects we we
not have a few feet we have a directive
to support daddy in the product
Chuncheon is quite general and the
lighting computing is is yeah it is also
press on the light light directions you
can specify images scare the light so
which is the light of our goal with the
the camera or you fixed using user
coordinates you can also specify
different colors sorry
or you can apply weight to them the
wheat is it is bother the intensity
computed from from the normal or under
lighting computing so that's an it
either or it also worked with or or the
color data set so you can apply
different color data and see the one and
because the ones you like
good good shadings it's little I receive
for the two shading it's it's more the
when since connecting are more it's more
sharp it has sharp connecting but good
Shetty's is smooth I see there are yeah
that's the difference and it gives a
quarter warm color transition and
steeples is so you can apply that to any
graphics 3d graphics you can control the
density of it and it will give some
different rendering yeah
hut-hut shading is with something allows
you to apply the hatching style or the
sketching style to any 3d graphics same
thing you can specify me to scared
lighting or user cornets lighting and
also you can choose to customize because
it's using textures you can also
customize using your own textures and
give Emma give different results like
here and you are if you are not very
satisfied with it I probably I want this
part to be to be totally white for the
highlight part so what I did is just
replace these two with just two white
textures and we evaluate that you are
see this part is why pure white so you
can put it in different textures you are
you you are you might customize your own
Hetchy shading yourself halftone we have
currently developer five hot on choices
like a disk hexagon line square triangle
and you can also can choose a distance
between them and that all these H now
NPO is for 3d and for 2d we also have
hatching entirely in a world work
definitely war work different lay
because does not highlighting for the
hatching for 2d it's you can can choose
the directions you might have more
styles coming
later and it were also adopted the the
the color with a graphics and if we want
something different you can specify your
heart self and for example if this works
does that okay okay so so so all the MPO
if you look deep closer to it you are
see that it is built on top of textures
and the surface appearance what is
surface appearance it is a directive we
we are currently experimenting with last
user to feeding GPU shared us directly
and you can choose the rendering
yourself
the syntax of where that is it is it is
this is one okay this this is why
example I'm going to use which called
the depth of field and if we look a
little closer about the structure it has
names attributes parameters and mainly
you will have [ __ ] shared programs
including the fragment shader a vertex
shader so you totally could decide what
it rendered and I so it could be used to
develop MP or it could also use for
customized rendering for yourself so in
this example I'm going to show you how
to do that with types of viuda so it
will get plurally if there are different
depths
so so if we take a look at the functions
it basically just to combine the color
Channel and the depth channel together
and then when we have a shadow what we
did is just doing some computing based
on these information and this is the
example and you can control these
parameters and if you do something
extreme yeah it will it would be
something different but it's flexible
you can create something you like and
publish it so this it could be used
applied to any data this is our geometry
3d data
currently it was sample a lot so it it
will be slow but if we reduce the number
in GP sample it will be the performance
where they where we get approved so mera
so we now have fully implemented maida
Mac and currently I'm demoing with metal
so it did we didn't see any problems
that means it's it's very close to be
ready and now let's take a look about
the performance there are some
performance boost and so these are some
numbers for simple ones it can get like
around 1020 percent performance boost
and but for those more expensive ones
you can you are see that it's more than
double the frame rate I can show you the
difference here it it what content I
think it contains millions polygons in
this example and you'll see the frame
rate is over here it's more it's smooth
yeah but still visible you are see it's
around like a three it's around 7 4
million polygons and if we switch to
open g oz open GSD around for option and
here are apple fully droplet so just in
case if you have see something driver
dependent issues you can always fall
back to okay choose yeah mm you are
so if it is open gr you are see it's
like 2.2 so yeah you are see there's a
performance boost there and this is
using Intel I I'm sure you are going to
get a much better numbers if you are
using nvidia and AMD because Mehta make
better use of these hardware's and we
also have fully implemented direct3d on
Windows and there are some numbers
comparing direct3d 9 Nam 9 and 11
so same object of course they are
running they are different machine so so
but these two are running on the same
machine your ass is that four simple
examples it's getting much better
performance it's like 80% performance
boot boost but if it was million getting
a little bit speed-up but I think we
were there are possibility to to getting
more optimized with the new ajayan layer
we have some new features for exam for
example like pixel based lighting
what is pixel based lighting it does
lighting computing currently we did
lighting computing our vertex level it's
it's not in pixel level but but in the
new junior it's computing it could could
be choose to running rendering under oh
I'm using OpenGL so that shows dunno
it's not available in OpenGL see
your kids get a much better lighting
that means you can sample less polygons
and the gate get ya to the same result
and the less polygons means faster and
with a new a new join layers we also
give the choice of you can choosing
different graphics hardware you know our
list other available hardware insisting
information so there's a part of made
her if you have multiple hardware's you
are listed here it also shows what which
ones currently in use but my wife's just
only got Intel so there's only one
listed here and if there's more you can
select hardware's
for different propers for example you
want to save the battery life for
example and you can choose different the
prefer the GPU there are software
integrated discrete it's not always
available all these case are available
but if it it's available Iowa system on
your machine it will be applied so try
to see now I'm going to demo something
with direct3d if I can switch to the
windows
so Mysterio is has been requested for
different different users for many years
but now we have it as a building feature
but it it only works with direct3d 11 we
did it in the same way as unity does so
if your hardware support that and you
can configure that in the Nvidia control
panel there are if you have if you have
the have the goggles you might give you
a choice have different stereo types
currently we does not have much
hardware's right now so we were just
demo in the
oh okay
yes my mouse put it up
yeah it's prototype okay let's try to
run this example
this is the volume rendering result
applying color functions to to example
data and if your hold on looking left a
Kentucky and try to interact with it it
will bring up the studio window if we
could also do for screen and if you have
classes you can see that and the USC the
performance is pretty good as well
it's a Nvidia graphics are RTX yeah two
sensors
yeah so
this is the future the steerer feature
with direct3d 11 and there's our let me
show you some the sister that I'm trying
to see how do our information I cannot
see so there's a d/dx it Wash U or the
hardware's currently available I am an
assistant for my desktop unregarded
software and NVIDIA meta does not have
software but direct3d 11 has software
okay so you can choose between them
using the prefer the GPU option and then
it what just works so I think I my
time's up do you have any questions
[Applause]